[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
JOHN DOLHUN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to The Ellen Swallow
Richards lab part two.
There is-- the room will
be a little bit more
sparsely populated today.
I wonder why.
Lab reports are due, right?
So we're going to get started.
And I'm going to start off by
talking about probably the most
important parameter in measuring
the health of the river,
and that's the dissolved
oxygen. So when
we look at the dissolved
oxygen concentrations
out there, for a river
to really be healthy,
we're looking for something
greater than probably about 8
PPM.
If the concentrations
fall down to 5 or less,
then you'll start to see the
fish move around erratically,
because they're trying
to get their oxygen.
So less than or equal to
5, and we have some stress
placed on the aquatic life.
If the dissolved
oxygen concentration
goes below 2, even
for an hour or two,
you're going to have fish kills.
So let's take a
moment to actually see
how this oxygen
gets into the water,
and this is the big picture.
So if you look at this, you've
got two processes going on.
You've got the oxygen coming
in from the atmosphere,
and it's diffusing
into the water system.
You also have down below, you've
got aerobic biodegradation
taking place.
So we've got oxygen
diffusing into the water,
and then we've got
aerobic biodegradation.
These are the two main
processes that are taking place,
and both of these
processes are going--
they have different kinetics,
yet they're coupled together,
coupled in the sense that if
aerobic biodegradation uses up
the oxygen, more oxygen
will start to dissolve in.
There's a transfer
driving force that
actually lets more oxygen
dissolve into the water.
The rate at which
oxygen is dissolving
is actually proportional
to the deficit of oxygen
that's in the river.
And that deficit is equal
to the equilibrium level
that we would expect
minus the actual level
that we actually find.
So the amounts of oxygen
that we're talking about
are very tiny.
And there was a
brilliant chemist
by the name of William Henry,
who actually, back in 1803,
came out with Henry's Law.
And what Henry's Law
says is very simple.
The solubility of a dissolved
gas in a body of water
is proportional to
the partial pressure
of that gas over the water.
There's even a Henry's
Law constant here,
and there are tables of these.
There are thousands of them.
For every solvent, for every
gas, for every temperature
combination that
you can think of,
there is a Henry Law constant
that you can plug in.
Let's think about, what
is the partial pressure
of oxygen on any given day?
How do we calculate that?
Yes, yeah.
Alec.
AUDIENCE: So if you
have total pressure,
and then you know the
makeup of the atmosphere.
You can just break it down.
So say your pressure
is 1 atmosphere
and you have 20% oxygen in
the at-- that's not right.
But 20% oxygen in
the atmosphere,
your oxygen would be
contributing 0.20 atmospheres
to the pressure [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN DOLHUN: Very good.
Very good, Alec.
So Alec said that you've got
20.9% oxygen in the atmosphere.
So we can convert
that to a decimal.
Partial pressure of
oxygen on any given day
would be the percent
of oxygen that's
in the atmosphere times
the atmospheric pressure
on that particular day minus
the pressure of the water vapor
that we're talking about.
So that gives us
a handle on this.
I want to show you
probably the simplest
example of Henry's Law.
I brought a bottle of Coke
here, and these are hard, right,
because they pack them--
there's a head of carbon
dioxide gas over the liquid.
Now when I open this, I'm
going to release the gas,
so the partial pressure of
CO2 over this liquid is gone.
We should start to see bubbles
coming out of the solution,
right?
[HISSING]
Oh good, it's not an
explosive one, so that's good.
So there are the bubbles of
the dissolved carbon dioxide
gas starting to come out.
And that's a simple
example of Henry's Law.
Can anybody think of a
more complex example?
Anybody a diver here?
Kelly, you're a diver?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no,
I'm just [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
When you--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's like the bends, right?
Because as you go down
further, the pressure
increases so that more nitrogen
can dissolve in your blood,
you said?
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah, very good.
Yeah, so you've got
gases in your blood.
And when you go
down, when you're
diving down under
a great pressure,
when you start your ascent,
all of those gas bubbles
are going to come out.
And they have to go somewhere.
They could migrate
anywhere in your body,
and it could cause a rash.
It could cause some
type of joint pain.
You could end up with
paralysis, even death.
So divers have to really,
really time their ascent.
That there's a name for that.
Kelly said the bends.
That's one of the names.
It's also called DCS,
Decompression Sickness.
That's a great example
of Henry's Law.
What about if we think about
temperature and dissolved
oxygen?
Let's actually take
a look at that.
Here is a graph of oxygen
concentration and temperature.
What stands out to you here?
Sean?
AUDIENCE: It decreases
exponentially with temperature.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah, as
the water is warming up,
look what's happening
to the dissolved oxygen.
Why do you think
that's happening?
And why, when the water is
cold, can we hold so much oxygen
in that cold water?
Kelly.
AUDIENCE: Is it because, as
the temperature increases,
the average kinetic
energy of the molecules
increases, and the
distribution broadens,
so more oxygen has
the ability to escape?
JOHN DOLHUN: Good, good.
As the temperature increases,
the kinetic energy of the water
molecules is
increasing, and they're
starting-- think about
when you boil water.
Bam, they're bubbling out.
That hydrogen bonding
network is gone.
All those intermolecular
forces of attraction are gone.
Now think about this side when
the water gets really cold
and you form this
hydrogen bonding network.
I mean, it expands, right?
Pipes break.
That's why our pipes break.
It's because of the hydrogen
bonding in the ice crystals
when they expand out.
But look at the crevices
here in these things.
So the oxygen molecules can
swim in and out of those,
and they can become weakly
trapped and pinned in.
And there you've got
a dramatic increase
in the amount of oxygen that can
dissolve in the colder waters.
The other thing to keep in mind
about the water is the heat
capacity of water
is much greater
than the heat capacity of air.
It takes a lot more
energy to change
the temperature of water.
I mean, you can--
I've gone out when
it's 85 degrees,
and I want to go for a
swim across from my house.
And I jump in, and
it's only 67 in there.
So the water hasn't caught up
to the temperature of the air.
Now there are a lot of
different equations out there
that actually would
let us calculate
the potential of a body of water
to hold oxygen, theoretically,
how much could be out
there on a given day.
And the more complex
the equation,
the better the results.
I found a couple
empirical, simple equations
that give really good results,
so I'm going to go with these.
And they're all based on
altitude and temperature.
If you look at
the equation, it's
all about the
atmospheric pressure,
the water vapor pressure, and
the temperature of the water,
which is in Celsius.
So if we look at that
equation, if the pressure,
the atmospheric
pressure goes up, right,
what happens to the dissolved
oxygen concentration?
If you're trying to
calculate the saturated level
of dissolved oxygen, and
the pressure goes up,
the atmospheric
pressure, what happens
to the DO concentration?
I promise this is
not a trick question.
This is-- Alec.
AUDIENCE: It increases.
JOHN DOLHUN: It
absolutely increases.
Yeah.
Now what happens if we
have a high water vapor
pressure that day?
You might be on a
mountaintop stream.
Water vapor pressure
is very high.
What happens to the DO?
Someone?
AUDIENCE: Decreases.
JOHN DOLHUN: Sam, decreases.
Good.
And the other situation, which
if the river temperature is
high, then it's
intuitive, right?
Your DO is going to be smaller.
So that's how you
use those equations.
And then what you can
do with the equation
is you can calculate a thing
called the percent saturation
level, which is the actual DO
that you get in the lab divided
by the potential of
water to hold oxygen
based on the temperature
and pressure above.
And that saturated
level is going
to tell us a lot about the
condition of the water.
Usually-- I mean, you could
have from 90% to 110%,
something like that.
That's normal.
If you get to 120%
or greater, that's
a problem, because there
are different diseases
that the fish can--
they have an oxygen bubble
disease fish can get
if it becomes too saturated.
So this is something that
you'll do these calculations,
and the TAs will
carry a pH meter.
They'll record the
air temperature,
the atmospheric
pressure, the river water
temperature each
day you go down,
and they'll put that
on the whiteboard.
Here is some simple
data that will
allow you to
interpolate the water
vapor pressures based
on temperatures.
And you can go in
between these, and you'll
get very good results.
If you can't find it on here,
you could use this equation.
But the T here is the
temperature of air,
and it's in Kelvin.
And back here, this
is the temperature
of the river in Celsius.
So don't get confused with that.
And now I'd like to spend
a few minutes talking
about the actual method that
we're going to use in this lab.
This method was
actually discovered
by a graduate student by the
name of Winkler back in 1888.
And the method has
withstood time.
What he did is he developed this
series of oxidation reduction
equations to actually
measure the dissolved oxygen
concentration in saltwater.
And he came up with this
series of equations.
And it's been 130 years,
and this is still here.
Today they have the fancy
dissolved oxygen meters,
which we're not using,
but you can just
drop it in and get your DO.
They used this method to
calibrate those meters today.
So you're using--
you're going to be
doing the real chemistry here.
The whole method is
based on that if you've
got oxygen in the
water, iodide is
going to get oxidized
to iodine, and you're
going to be able to titrate the
iodine with sodium thiosulfate.
So let's just go through the
method just a little bit here.
So we start with
manganese sulfate,
and we form a white precipitate.
But if oxygen is
present in the water,
oxygen is an
oxidizing agent here.
It's going to oxidize
this manganese hydroxide
to this tetravalent
manganic species.
So you've got manganese over
here, which is a plus 2,
and over here,
you've got a plus 4.
There are a couple--
in the literature, there's
some argument about this.
Some people feel the
species is a trivalent,
and they're saying it's MnOH3.
So on this side, you'd have a
trivalent manganese species.
Other people are
saying no, it's MnO2.
It's a hydrated form of mnO2.
It's tetravalent.
What I've done is I've
combined both these
to give you this manganic
species here, which works.
This is tetravalent.
So notice that when
you've formed this,
this is like a brown flock.
You've captured the
oxygen at this point.
Now you've got to dissolve
that, so we add sulfuric acid
to dissolve that
brown precipitate.
And then there's
iodide in there.
So this oxidized manganese
will oxidize iodide to iodine.
We can then detect it
with sodium thiosulfate,
and the iodine gets reduced
back down to iodide.
If you look at this, for every
oxygen, every one oxygen,
you make to manganic species.
Each manganic species
gives you one I2,
and each I2 requires
two thiosulfate.
So that's a 4 to 1 ratio,
thiosulfate to oxygen.
So let's take a look at
your first day, which
is the standardization
of the thiosulfate.
We have to know exactly what
the concentration of that
is when we titrate the river
water to actually get-- to home
in on the exact concentration.
So we're going to be using a
primary standard, potassium
biiodate.
Does anybody know what the
qualities of a primary standard
are?
When you pick a
primary standard,
it's pretty important.
You want something that
has certain properties.
Anybody ever worked
with a primary standard?
No?
OK, well, first thing,
notice how big this is.
It has a very high
formula weight.
So that's actually a good thing.
Not all primary
standards have that.
When you mass it
out, you're going
to have less error on
the balance because
of the mass of this thing.
Also, it has to be
something that's pure.
And this is like 99.9% pure.
The other thing is
you need something
that does not have any
water vapor attached,
no attached water.
The TAs put this in the oven.
So no hydrated water.
And then the final
thing is, you want--
it should be stable at room
temperature and when heated.
And oftentimes we'll
look at the cost, too.
That's another factor
that comes into play.
But what you're
going to do is you're
going to weigh out
0.0818 grams of this.
And if you divide by the
molecular weight of that,
you'll get moles.
And you're going to
make a 100-mil solution.
So divide that by 0.1
liters, and you'll
get your concentration.
You're actually making up
something like a 0.0021 molar
solution of that standard.
And then you're going to
use that to standardize
your thiosulfate.
We're also going to be using
starch in this reaction.
So why do you think
we need to use starch
when we're titrating something?
Alec.
AUDIENCE: Starch
reacts with iodide,
and it creates the
blue color so that when
we react-- when
we were titrating,
it could turn really pale.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So it was really hard
to tell if it was clear or not.
So I think the starch helps
indicate whether or not
you've gotten rid of
all of the iodide.
Iodide, yeah.
JOHN DOLHUN: Good.
Good.
That's very good.
So starch actually reacts
with iodide and iodine,
gives you that blue-black color.
So if you're titrating
something yellow to clear,
sometimes it might
be harder to see.
So what Alec said
was your solution
actually reacts with starch.
So I actually brought some
of the solution in here,
and I brought a
piece of bread in.
I don't know if this
is going to work,
but bread has starch
in it, doesn't it?
So I'm going to put
someone on this bread.
Wow.
Look at that blue black.
So something's going on here.
It's reacting with
the starch, right?
Can I have a volunteer?
Some brave person?
I know you're all
tired, but one of you.
One of you, come up.
Come on up, Maida.
Maida, right?
It's Maida, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
Maida, stand up front here.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to open this up.
And put a pair of
these on, Maida.
And I'm going to let
you hold this beaker
and face your fellow students.
And just hold it nice and--
and what we're
going to do is we're
going to add something to it.
It's clear, right?
OK, keep your eye on the beaker.
Maida, don't drop
but whatever you do.
AUDIENCE: I won't drop it.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
[CHUCKLES]
OK.
So keep your eye on that beaker.
Don't take your
eyes off the beaker.
Now what-- don't worry.
Keep watching it, Maida.
Don't get nervous.
Oh!
Now that's what
I'm talking about.
You see that?
This is what we're
talking about.
And I mean, you're titrating.
You can't see the end point.
You put this in, now that
last drop of titrant,
it's going to turn it clear.
You're going to be able
to see your titration.
And thank you very much, Maida.
So what's going on
with the starch?
Let's take a look at this.
Starch is made up of
about 25% amylose, which
is the linear helical form.
And it also is made up about
75% of the branched amylopectin.
What happens is we have
iodine and iodide present
in our solution, and when
those two come together,
they actually form
this pentaiodide anion.
So you've got some
I2, some I minus.
Remember, I2 is amber.
I minus is clear.
When you get these
two together and they
insert into this helix, the
amylose helix of starch,
and what amylose does is it
forces the pentaiodide anion
to go in linearly
into that helix.
Then the energy spacings change.
So you've got-- the way the
wavelength of light hits
that, you're going
to see blue black.
It's all happening inside of
the starch with the amylose.
That's the key thing.
There are different people--
some people still
believe it's I3 minus.
There's somebody else out
there saying no, no, it's
a polyiodide.
There's always going to be
some controversy in the--
but they're working on it.
I like I5.
And someone actually
made an inorganic complex
to make it look like starch,
and they proved it was I5.
But even after this
paper came out,
there's still a lot
of controversy, so.
So for your standardization,
pretty simple.
You're going to go
through, and you're
going to just
follow these steps.
The TAs will go through
this with you, very simple.
And you're going to
start off with probably
something like this, kind
of like a reddish solution.
And then you're going to
start adding your thiosulfate.
And gradually, your titrating
the iodine in this solution
to iodide.
So here you've got a
more yellow solution.
What you want to do is you want
to find a spot when it turns
yellow to add your starch.
And the starch has to be
bubbly hot on the hot plate.
And if you add it
too early, there's
so much iodine in
there, it's going
to destroy the starch complex.
You won't get a reaction.
But if you wait until it's
so pale yellow, what happens,
Thomas?
AUDIENCE: It turns blue.
It makes the complex
successfully,
it turns it dark blue.
JOHN DOLHUN: It
turns it dark blue.
Yeah.
But if you wait
too long, right--
AUDIENCE: [? I ?] [? mean, ?]
if you add too much, [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Did you--
you had a reaction
yesterday where your starch
was an globules, right?
Is that--
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah.
It formed a film because
we didn't keep it hot.
JOHN DOLHUN: Oh, the
starch was not hot enough.
OK, that explains that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We put
it in and stirred,
and it made a bunch of little
blue specks that [INAUDIBLE]..
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes, yes.
Yeah, I've seen that before.
So you want to keep your starch
hot, and just be patient.
And then you just take a
plastic pasture pipette,
take a swig of it,
shoot it in, and you
should get your blue black.
And then look.
You've got your blue black.
You put that last drop
of thiosulfate in,
and you've got your
clear solution.
So you turn around, and
you're writing this down
in your notebooks, right,
and then you look back,
but it's starting to
turn blue black again.
What should you do?
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: Add another
drop of titrant.
JOHN DOLHUN: Add
another drop of titrant.
That's what I would do, Thomas.
But it's not correct.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JOHN DOLHUN: But I
would do the same thing.
I would add another
drop of titrant.
AUDIENCE: Oh, what if it
just turned blue by itself,
[INAUDIBLE] and you're
just [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: There's a side
reaction going on in the air.
When you get this
clear, you've got
all iodide present in there.
But what happens is--
so you've got iodide
there, but you also
have oxygen in the air.
And the oxygen is oxidizing
the iodide to iodine,
and we don't want this
iodine coming from the air.
We want it only from
the river water,
right, from the
oxygen in the river.
So this is a side reaction that
can go on if you let it set.
So just ignore it.
Just take your end point,
your final neutralization,
and you're good.
Take a look at the
stoichiometry here.
One biiodate make six I2.
Each I2 reacts with
two thiosulfate.
So it's 12 to 1
thiosulfate to biiodate.
What you're going
to do is you're
going to do three trials,
and they all should agree to
within 2% or 3%.
If they don't, do an
extra trial or two.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to find your mean,
your standard deviation,
and your confidence
intervals and then give all
that information to your TA.
Yesterday the TAs
did a beautiful job.
They put everybody's on
an Excel spreadsheet,
had it all averaged out.
They really did a
good job yesterday.
The students really homed in
on the exact concentration
of the thiosulfate.
So it's pretty simple.
You do your calculations
right there in the lab.
And then you have a choice
of using the class average
or using your own results for
the dissolved oxygen that will
take place on the next day.
So collection of water samples.
So you're going to be going
to the river for day two.
And we have these poles.
If you have long arms,
you'll take a short poll.
If you're short and
have short arms,
then we have real long poles.
They're like hockey sticks.
So you get your stick, and what
you do is you insert your--
your BOD bottle snaps into
the clip that I've got inside.
You take the stopper
out, and then you
go to the edge of the dock.
Don't fall in, and
don't push anybody, OK.
Remember the cyanobacteria
and all that out there.
And take gloves with
you, because when
you put this under water, it's
got to be completely submerged.
You have to reach over the dock.
You've got to stopper
it underwater.
So you've got to have
gloves with you, all right.
So I stoppered mine underwater.
I bring it up, take it out,
and then I look at the--
I take the bottle,
and I do this test.
I don't see any bubbles.
That's a good sign.
That means it's perfect.
If you see bubbles, you've
introduced more oxygen
in there.
Your DO concentrations
are going to be too high.
Pour it out, and restart again.
OK, so that's the collection.
Then you bring the
stuff back to the lab,
and you're going to treat
the bottles in the lab.
This here is wrong.
You don't want to use these
digital pipetters to treat
the water, because you'll
be introducing oxygen
into those water bottles.
What you're going to use is
your 10-mL glass pipette.
And what we're
going to do here is
each pair of students
will have four bottles.
So you're going to--
first, you're going to treat it
with the manganese sulfate, 2
mLs of manganese sulfate.
That's the first reaction
on that oxidation reduction
Winkler series.
And the way you do it
is-- what I would do
is I would take up 10
mils of manganese sulfate
to prevent any airflow, any air.
And then what you're
going to do is you're
going to take the stopper out.
You're going to go just below
the surface of the liquid
and put in 2 mils.
And then your partner
can stopper it.
You go to the next one.
You do all four of them.
The last 2 mils in here,
shoot it into waste.
And then do the same thing
with the alkaline-iodide-azide
reagent, 2 mils in each bottle.
And you should look at
the bottle at this point.
After you add those
reagents, there
should not be any bubbles.
If there's a bubble, it
means you've introduced air,
and your DO values will
be higher by doing that.
So once you've treated with
these two steps here, you've
essentially trapped
the oxygen. You're
going to have this
brown flock like this.
Now you just shake that
a bit, and then you're
going to dissolve it now
by adding sulfuric acid, 28
drops of sulfuric.
Acid for the sulfuric, you
don't go below the surface.
You just open the lid,
and you drip, drip it in.
The acid is heavy.
It's going to fall right to
the bottom of the bottle.
And now you should
have a bubble in there.
You will have a bubble
after you add the sulfuric,
and that's OK.
So when you're done with
this, you're ready to titrate.
And we've got to-- we're
supposed to titrate 200 mils.
That's what you titrated when
you did your standardization as
well.
But we've got to make
up for the 4 mils
that we added there
in the beginning.
We've displaced something there.
So you want to titrate
200 mLs times--
you've got a 300 mL BOD bottle,
and you've taken and added
4 mLs of stuff to it.
So if you do the math
to make up for that,
you really have to
titrate 203 mLs.
So there's a couple
ways you could do this.
You can use a 100-mL graduated
cylinder, and the error on that
is about plus or minus 0.5.
You fill that up twice,
put that in your container.
The last 3 mils, you could
use this for accuracy
to get your last 3 mLs
in, and then you're good.
But you can also
just titrate 200 mLs
and then multiply your answer
by a correction factor, which
would be 203 over 200.
And that will give you the same
answer as titrating the 203.
So the math is
pretty simple here.
You're converting the
moles of your titrant
to moles of oxygen,
grams of oxygen.
You divide by the liters.
If you're doing 200
mLs, that's 0.2 liters.
And then you get your
milligrams per liter in PPM.
I kept mentioning
we're using the--
we've got to add this
alkaline-azide solution.
We're actually using
the azide modification
of the Winkler method.
And what is that?
Well, there are NOx
gases in the atmosphere.
What's the nastiest NOx
gas that you can think of?
I'll give you a hint.
It's a big greenhouse
gas, and it's not CO2.
AUDIENCE: Ozone?
JOHN DOLHUN: Ozone is
a gas up there, yeah.
But that protects us.
Our ozone layer is a
layer of protection.
But what's-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it NO2 or--
JOHN DOLHUN: The other way.
AUDIENCE: Or N O?
I know that [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: All right,
please don't laugh at this.
It's laughing gas, N2O.
You're all-- I
mean, the atmosphere
is loaded with laughing gas.
I know.
Everybody's laughing now.
It's great.
Where does it come from, N2O?
All the fertilizer.
1% of all the
fertilizer in the world
goes up in the atmosphere
as laughing gas.
It's not from a
dentist's office.
It's from fertilizer.
I know.
I don't want to
think about dentists.
I was just at one yesterday.
I don't like dentists.
But every ton of laughing
gas that's in the atmosphere.
is like 300 tons of CO2.
And it stays up there
for over 100 years.
And what does it do?
Well, who said ozone back there?
There you are.
OK.
Laughing gas reacts
with ozone, and it
forms dinitrogen dioxide.
And this dinitrogen dioxide
only lasts for about an hour.
And immediately, the N2O2
reacts with air and water
to form nitrites.
And here we are talking about
greenhouse gas in the world,
and this is affecting our little
tiny reaction in the Charles
River experiment, because these
nitrites, look what they do.
They get in and oxidize
iodide to iodine.
And we don't want
our iodine coming
from some reaction from laughing
gas, right, from nitrite.
We want it coming from
the oxygen in the river.
So we add sodium azide.
And that zaps the
nitrites, convert them
to harmless nitrogen and water.
So that's the theory
behind why we're
using the azide modification.
All that for these nitrites.
So let's talk for a moment
about pH, pH in natural waters.
Let's see here.
Pulling down some board, here.
Who knows the definition of pH?
Remember your chemical
principles from a long time a--
Alec.
AUDIENCE: I think it was log
of concentration of hydrogen
ions, [INAUDIBLE] ions.
JOHN DOLHUN: Very good.
The negative log of the
concentration of the hydrogen
ions.
So pH.
And I mean, you all know
the pH scale is 0 to 14,
and acid is less than 7.
And I hope you know what color
litmus paper changes, right,
with pH.
That was a question on a
TV show with Regis Philbin,
You Want to Be a Millionaire.
A guy actually got up to
the million dollar question.
And I happened to turn
it on just at that point,
and they ask him,
what color does
litmus paper change in base?
And the guy said,
oh, I don't know,
but can I call my lifeline?
And they said yes.
So he called this
prestigious biologist
at one of the
California universities.
And they said red.
[LAUGHTER]
And the guy answers red, and
he loses the million dollars.
Oh, I was beside myself.
So if you remember anything,
remember what color
litmus paper is in acid.
But in the river, the pH
can go from 6.5 to 8.5.
And the pH effects everything,
from the solubility of metals--
if it gets too acidic
out there in the river,
the metals become more soluble,
mercury, cadmium, arsenic,
all those metals.
So the fish uptake the
metals, and we eat the fish.
And with global warming,
the acidity of the rivers
is gradually drifting
very slightly lower.
It also affects the
forms of phosphorous.
So remember, you've
got PO4 to the 3 minus.
But if it's slightly
acidic, you might
have the hydrogen phosphate
or the dihydrogen phosphate.
Or you could end up
with phosphoric acid,
depending on how acidic it gets.
What about
photosynthesis and pH?
Where are my biologists
at, my resident bi--
there must be somebody
in bio in here.
Come on.
Don't be afraid.
Yes.
There you are.
What's the equation
for photosynthesis?
AUDIENCE: Water
and carbon dioxide.
JOHN DOLHUN: Good, good.
Water and carbon dioxide.
Let's just write that
down for a moment.
So CO2 plus water,
little bit of sun.
AUDIENCE: Oxygen and glucose.
JOHN DOLHUN: Oxygen
and sugars, good.
So CH2O, n.
So does the pH go up or
down during photosynthesis?
I mean, it's like
a 50/50 chance.
Sean, you want to
answer, don't you?
AUDIENCE: I would
say the pH goes up.
JOHN DOLHUN: It goes up?
OK.
Anyone else?
Alec?
AUDIENCE: It goes down?
JOHN DOLHUN: It goes down?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
There you go.
I told you it's
like a 50/50, right?
All right, let's do a
little experiment with this.
I'm going to pour
myself a drink here.
This is good stuff.
It's not Gatorade,
I can tell you that.
This is a classic test in
the medical profession,
if you're going to medical
school, for breath.
And when I'm doing this,
you cannot make me laugh.
If you make me
laugh, I'm dead, OK.
Please.
I'm going to play some
music to relax myself here.
Let me just-- let me see
if we can get this on here.
OK.
There we go.
So I'm breathing into this.
We don't hear any
music coming out.
Going to--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There we go.
You're making me laugh, Sean.
I may have to have you come
up and help me with this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I may not be OK.
The color's supposed to change.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There we are.
Good?
I'm OK.
So what just happened?
AUDIENCE: You blew carbon
dioxide into the water.
JOHN DOLHUN: I blew carbon
dioxide in the water.
So we've got CO2 plus
water going to what?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Carbonic acid.
JOHN DOLHUN: Carbonic acid.
Good.
H2CO3, which breaks down
into H plus plus bicarbonate.
Now photosynthesis needs
carbon dioxide, right?
So we take that out
of the equation,
which means we're also
taking out the H plus.
So does the pH go up or down?
AUDIENCE: Up.
JOHN DOLHUN: Alec?
Up, up, up.
OK?
Good.
And pollution and
pH, same thing.
If you've got pollution,
you've got all this vegetation.
So you've got photosynthesis,
so the pH is going to be up.
This is Lassen Lake, Volcanic
National Park, pH 2, 2.0.
You do not want to stick
your foot into this lake.
And then you've got some
safety of the chemicals, which
the most serious is the
azide reagent, which
it's a neurological toxin.
And if you ingest it,
it can cause death.
So please be careful with that.
Sulfuric acid, you
know how bad that is.
You don't want to get it
in your respiratory system.
And the manganese
sulfate seems innocuous,
but it attacks the
central nervous system,
targets blood and kidneys.
So be careful with that.
Sodium thiosulfate is
a respiratory irritant,
can cause breathing problems.
So if you feel like you're
having breathing issues,
it could be that.
Biiodate can burn your eyes.
Very, very dangerous
stuff around your eyes.
So all of these things, you
have to be careful with.
OK.
So we'll see you Thursday
for the last lecture
in this series.